it's now been 305 days since Russia
mounted its invasion of Ukraine with
bobbing campaigns hitting mainly the
east of the country over the Christmas
period were Ukraine's counter-attacks
are causing a headache for Moscow as the
Russian front line has been pushed back
but now Ukraine's military response
proves it can now hit where the bombers
are coming from in Russia the angles II
air base is 600 kilometers from the
Ukrainian border Skies ustra albigir
reports from Ukraine's Capital Kiev for
the second time in just three weeks
Russia's Engels Air Base has been hit by
a Ukrainian drone
this time fatally wounding three
military personnel
Moscow says they were killed by the
falling wreckage as the low-flying Drone
was shot down Engels is a major
Strategic Air Base for Russia so this is
a huge reputational blow for them there
is a high risk of retaliation but
airstrikes here in Ukraine have been so
frequent and so brutal that people here
are going about their business as normal
Ukraine's military is known to be
guarded around attacks inside Russian
territory their Air Force spokesperson
Yuri Ignat spoke to us about the blasts
um
whether Ukraine confirms or denies the
attack Russia still has to face the
reputational damage foreign
foreign